[Music]
oh [ __ ] although
[Music]
one's the gladiator rep you know that's
a good question
oh but let me see what rep I am oh I
think I'm close so I'm not entirely sure
if I hit it or not [ __ ]
so yeah as you guys can see I'm just a
little bit late on the ref 40 gladiator
duels but yeah guys welcome back to a
brand new video Rebecca I'm for my games
that are gonna be doing as the title
says some rep 42 look gladiator like I
said a little bit late but it's better
late than never as always good to just
be doing some duels with the glider
you're probably gonna use the winter
soldier off is probably the best-looking
plumie as in this game they'll collapse
from chic sandals you already know
what's going on with that like the V
feed do enjoy subscribe for new I
covered the informational side of
foreigner that being balance changes
hero updates new events new patch notes
hero updates leaks all that good stuff
as well as doing some gladiator gameplay
and some future gameplay on the new
heroes as well with that let's get into
these duels for today I'm the first
match today is gonna be against a
berserker didn't really quite check the
rubber f15 pretty nice I'm not like like
I've stated multiple times in the past
not really good against berserkers but
I'll get that starting heavy off pretty
nice [ __ ] up the guard break but I'd
screw it up and did a toe step but at
least I'm getting damage no hate there
this man's gonna light spammy to death
your boy thrown on the light damn maybe
one more I'm doing this before doing
this again I'll just hit it with the
zone he misses the parry no problem
jumping light
ah good stuff try to go on the back
dodge I also tried to problem possibly
like I don't know what I was thinking to
be honest I was trying to back up when
he was doing the light since I'm not
really that great appearing Berserker
lights but I'm getting I'm trying to get
a little bit better hopefully if we
could try to take this in round 2 I am
this is probably like my second or third
duel on today so I'm just uh I'm just a
little bit rusty haven't played too much
and of course bazookas aren't really my
strong suit just because of the really
fast lights on console I'm not really
feeling with it all right a lot of hyper
armor there I got to watch out heavy
will [ __ ] me up right now that it's
gonna be GG good if I did definitely
screwed up on the side what does that
side light yes the side light for
Berserker that definitely threw him off
I'm getting good at pairing those
they're literally just like a row cheese
and gladiators so I've gotten real good
to pairing those moves and stuff like
that that kind of screwed me up I'm
really glad I managed to kill him though
he's giving me real worried we started
whipping at me with the hyper armor some
of the few things about Berserker is
that the hyper armor is just the one
thing you have to worry about and that's
why I'm not deflecting this match as
much as I would love to deflect this guy
right now I don't want to because the
hyper armor is gonna screw me up in the
end it's gonna be completely redundant
thank you for the free heavy
just playing super passive right now
just letting him do his thing throw out
his own real quick one heavy will kill
him that's good stuff good stuff all
right I tried not to use the dash
attacks such as this
I forgot what they're called but the
dash sidelights is and stuff like that
as much because obviously that's going
to lead into a block if it's blocked
it's a free guard break against me and I
don't want that but he seems to not be
blocking these and I've done this for
the past three rounds so I'm not going
to do it this time I'm just gonna follow
up with a simple guard break and he
falls right into the trap doing the easy
bread-and-butter mix-up he notices that
I can't really parry these lights too
often so he just starts whipping the
lights one at a time and it's really
working out for him what sucks
didn't mean to the back dodged this ones
I'm gonna let that rip good fly did one
of the few reasons why I did that is
because I was really close to out of
stamina and I didn't want to do the full
out of stamina punished with just heavy
fain too heavy so I didn't want to do
that and as well I was getting really
nervous I tried to do this side dodge
but end up going backwards instance the
back down Joyner if they really did [ __ ]
me but I managed to take that run pretty
nice I'm really pressing myself actually
that bizarre could have done a lot more
damage against me but now let's get into
Game two in the second game we're on the
same map which kind of sucks trying to
go diversity here but we're fighting
Allah bring a rep 10 Stoney Maloney like
the name now once again I'm also really
not great against the log bringer but I
am pretty damn good at deflecting some
of their attacks specifically their
lights and their heavies as well not too
much not some of the lights it's mostly
the the top light I'm pretty good at
getting because that seems to be their
favorite combos to their favorite light
to start out with since it is pretty
quick so we see if I cap off a defect
here
Oh didn't mean the Dodge backer that's
gonna be a side heavy meant to dodge to
the side do a little side dodge action
but he saw that coming pretty quickly
hit it with the zone real quick oh good
good stop with the top light there falls
that up with a random shove into heavy
was a little bit out of the range so I
decided to poke in have you see if I got
an inseam to work and with the toe stabs
always see if we could do in round two
trying to let's see if I can mix things
up a bit really close on that deflects a
bit early actually
I could walk does it again I'm going for
it oh good stuff ah [ __ ] I was I was
honestly not expecting him to throw that
I was expecting another slight bite I
was gonna go for the buckler punch there
but I cuz I just want to get some
stamina damage out of him I was not
expecting that top light but I managed
the guard I'm in to deflect it but I
kind of [ __ ] myself cuz I didn't I
didn't do anything afterwards so it's
kind of sucks for me quick toast stab
and he's also one more toast that boy
from death if I can get anything else
out of him here ah good stuff I was
getting a little cocky there I was
trying to pull off a deflect as a quick
ender when I could've just went in
literally did any move man's got a
sliver of health getting a little cocky
definitely not want to be doing that in
fights I get I do that too often cuz I'm
a little bit of a deflect or I try I've
I'd full fish for D flex as much as I
can that's my issue little lag on that
guard break
all right well he disconnected all right
to game three we go
next stop is against a shaman I this is
probably the one character I cannot be
in for honor the only one that I can't
beat that was supposed to be a light
damn I thought that [ __ ] was a light
attack for some reason she's one of the
few I could beat her in a at 4v4 like
not too bad but like duels odds just
she's too much for me so we're gonna try
something we're gonna try some stuff
here I'm all trouble we'll see it was
even clutches out
oh good dodge you know she even though
you dodged into a [ __ ] sandbag good
dodge the walked into her alright she's
used she's utilizing the dash forward
heavies a lot which is really good
because a simple dash light would just
completely negate that which is amazing
so if she keeps using it if she if this
stoned joint here keeps using it a lot
then I might actually be end of I might
end up winning this game who knows it's
going damn but those gonna work thought
those gonna land good dodge followed up
with a deflect didn't do anything up
thanks chief I'm missing these I'm
missing these crucial hits right now
damn that's three times she did that
move I got it I got it the first time
the first time she did it and now I
can't get it again I think it's honestly
I think I'm just getting a little nerve
right I'm just a little nervous fighting
this character and then I just [ __ ] up
because I'm almost there like I've I'm
definitely I'm like pressing the button
I'm just a little bit late by like maybe
a few milliseconds so I'm almost started
to getting that move said that I can't
really do much off of it it's only just
the zone attack but it's still good but
it's just not really as much as I would
have hoped because this shit's pretty
quick for it being at a heavy input and
I did heavy again gotta stop that it's
just a reaction for me to do that
because I'm so used to doing like a row
cheese and surfers ones and those are
considered light parries and this isn't
and it just throws me off a lot all
right good stuff getting better getting
a little bit better fighting her still
really difficult though hopefully we can
win this
[Music]
[Music]
we're on 4c we could pull off gonna
start out with the sprint attack that
was a really dumb idea I can't tell if
she's like dodging these she is dodgy
okay
so she is dodging these based off of a I
[ __ ] up hold up
she's dodging those based off of
reaction I think and not just because
she loves the side dodges cuz those
could also be something that she likes
cuz she seems to like those a lot
oh good cluck what a close [ __ ] game
oh my god
started off the game it started off be
round with a sprint attack basically
almost killed myself there and then
ended up somehow getting super lucky
with the random heavy being thrown so
that was a close match GG shaman I'm
very happy that I even managed to be
here let's continue out the next game
and the last match of today is gonna be
against the conch I think roof for
honour really just wants me to fight a
bunch of people I don't know I'm not
confident against fighting in terms of
characters and this dudes like rep
140-something but he's like he's like
three with conch which is still good
alright interesting see if I can manage
to win this good 5 D
does that pretty quickly
his [ __ ] lights did good fight damn
bro his lights are so crazy that's why I
telling you I'm not that great against
conch either
well first game we had a berserker
didn't really not confident against
Berserker they had a love ring or not
confidence tame or shaman in every
single opponent this entire video has
just been characters I'm really not good
at fighting
I meant to dodge backwards that works
the game bro I mean those let's just
kick my ass he is one heavy tack away so
I could just whip one like that and it
worked I like to do this from time to
time they probably probably shouldn't do
that though cuz it really [ __ ] me up
but it seems to be working half the time
I do it though it's a good fight I'm
gonna see what I can pull off in the
later rounds but I'm still I don't know
how I'm gonna go against the infinite
light chain of him I got against conch
it's gonna be the one issue that I don't
like about conch is that so I'm gonna
try to I'm gonna try to fight him over
here first off I'm not trying to get
legit into a wall right now that would
really hinder me at the moment
good block did the box
damn I don't really know what the
correct way to punish this thing is just
I don't like cuz I can't cuz just me
punching him is not going to do anything
in terms of like just hitting him with
my buckler shield because that's just
not gonna do damage I'm looking for like
so I'm trying to try to confirm some
stuff here dad so don't look it for its
ancient and health or enough good flight
did I did the deef like the first time
but it was like the original one I think
against the law bringer yeah where I
tried to where I was just trying to do a
different move and it just happened to
connect at the same time but the second
time that was planned so I'm really glad
I managed to land that cuz that
definitely turned the tide on that
flight just a little bit more hopefully
one more round I can I need one more
round I can win against this conch which
would be just perfect unlike the shaman
though he doesn't he's not really
dodging these as often his own attacks
which is perfect cuz I don't want that
hits me with that crush encounter that
30 damage in one hit I can't stand that
movie couldn't really do anything off of
his out of stamina so that really he
took a W for that one
one led attack away I went for the back
dodge instead I was thinking that he was
gonna hit me with the shield bash then
followed the confirmed lights that's why
I went to backup but that ended up not
working
going into the round five go hopefully
we can it's two to two hopefully I can
somehow win this at the last round I
don't want to lose this fight
it is very closest guys a pretty damn
good Connick I'm also pretty bad against
conch in general so it's not really
helping we're gonna try some stuff hits
me with that heavy that's not a good way
to start this at all all right that was
close
call me quakin
[Music]
this man's bro
this man's oh it's gonna be Gigi if I
did one of the huge problems I noticed
during that last few seconds is that I
went for the heavy and then to the heavy
faint and then I realized how low my
health was or my low my stamina was and
then I ended up becoming out of stamina
which sucks cuz then obviously the
lights in out of stamina don't just
immediately bounce off they keep going
as if there were heavy tax and then that
led him into the shoulder rash with
which ultimately ended in my death but
yeah guys it's going to be the end of
the vid said I hope you guys did enjoy
this time was a little bit different
from the last time we did a gladiator
video I managed to do I did one extra
run because that guy quit halfway
through and I managed to lose one game
which sucks it was close super close
just some minor mistakes that I'll have
to hopefully not do in the future of
course because that's the whole point of
these just learning from their mistakes
but yeah I like to be if you do enjoy
guys I plan on doing a video once I hit
rep 50 with him as well doing eight
duels for him just like I do whatever up
40 except this time on time and not like
a month or a couple weeks afterwards and
I also plan on streaming once I hit rep
49 because I'm gonna be streaming the
entire time at firm rep 49 to 50 so we
can all be there once I unlock a rep 50
with glided which be awesome to do can't
wait to be streaming that whenever that
date happens to release I don't I just
gotta start grinding from now on be I
liked if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new like I said I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being belts changes hero leaks new
updates new patch notes all that stuff
the new the news of for honor and as
well some gladiator gameplay and game
play on the new heroes as well whenever
they happen to release in October yeah
my two most recent videos will be on
screen if you guys want to check that
out that guy's super yesterday thanks
for watching the video and peace out